SHE'D BEEN ACTIVELY
FREEING SLAVES.
SHE SAID, YOU KNOW WHAT,
JAMES BROWN.
JOHN BROWN.
[laughing]
JOHN BROWN,
A FAMOUS ABOLITIONIST,
WHO WAS A WHITE MAN--
YOU KNOW,
HE'S TRYING TO FREE SLAVES.
HERE'S MY MONEY.
HERE'S $30,000
SO YOU CAN BUY GUNS AND STUFF.
THEY BUY LAND IN CANADA
BECAUSE THEY'RE GONNA OPEN
A HOME AND FARM
SO THAT THESE FREED SLAVES
CAN GO LIVE.
JOHN BROWN GETS CAUGHT,
AND THEY FIND A LETTER ON HIM
THAT SAYS SOMETHING LIKE,
HEY, I'M IN SUPPORT OF YOU
AND I'M GONNA KEEP BEING
IN SUPPORT OF YOU.
JUST MAKE
SOME [bleep] HAPPEN.
AND INSTEAD OF M.E.P.,
IT LOOKED LIKE W.E.P.
SO IT WAS PUBLISHED
EVERYWHERE.
EVERYBODY BE ON THE LOOKOUT
FOR SOME DICK NAMED W.E.P.
WHERE WAS I AT,
HISTORICALLY?
- MM-MM.
- AT THAT TIME, SHE WAS IN LOVE
WITH A MAN NAMED THOMAS BELL.
HE WAS A SCOTSMAN.
[romantic music playing]
HE WAS A BUSINESSMAN.
AND SHE LOVED HIM.
[music stops]
THAT IS--
THAT WAS NOT ME FARTING.
THAT'S...THE...CHAIR.
AND THEY HAD BUSINESSES
TOGETHER,
MEANING LAUNDRIES,
AND BLAH, BLAH, BLAH,
AND BULL[bleep].
AND TOGETHER,
THEY AMASSED A FORTUNE
OF $30 MILLION.
WHICH, LIKE, NOWADAYS...
IS LIKE A BATRILLION GILLION
A-DOLLARS.
IN, LIKE, ONE
OF THE "CENSUSESES,"
SHE OUTTED HERSELF
AS A BLACK WOMAN.
WHEN THE LOVE OF HER LIFE,
THOMAS BELL, DIED,
PEOPLE STARTED TALKING
ABOUT HER BADLY.
THEY--
WHAT'S IT CALLED?
THEY "DISMISSINATED" HER.
THEY "SHENAMENANATED" HER.
THEY [talking gibberish] HER.
[laughing]